جبهه مماثله مقابل للجنود الاوكرانيين
يقود المواجهه فيها مهندسون وعمال صيانه
الكهرباء ففي ما وصف باهم جبهات الحرب
تاتي حمايه شبكه الكهرباء في اوكرانيا مع
الاستهداف الروسيه المتكرر لها وفقه صحيفه
وصف الجورن الامريكيه ساعات طويله محفوفه
بالمخاطر تمضيها طواقم ما سمي بكتيبه
الكهربائيين للاسراع باعاده بناء الشبكه
وتامين الاناره والتدفئه لملايين
الاوكرانيين عناصرها يواجهون خطر القصف
المستمر في يتواجهون للملائكه عندما تنطلق
تحضيرات الغارات الجويه او يحتمون حيثما
حيثما ام كانهم تحت الجسور مثلا اما
العمال الموجودون قرب الخطوط الاماميه
فيرتدون دروعا واقيه مع الحاجه الى
مرافقنا عسكريين وقد لقي ما لا يقل عن 10
اشخاص نصرعهم اثناء العمل منذ اكتوبر
الماضي في ما عدا بعض العمال من التقاعد
ليحل محل المئ الذين التحقوا بالقوات
المسلحه خطط الصيانه تشمل فرقا مكونه من
تسعه افراد للعمل في ثلاث
مناوبات على مدار 24 ساعه هذه الفرق تفكك
المحاولات المدمره او المعطله وتستبدلها
غير انه المحولات عفوا غير ان البلاد
تنفذ من هذه او تنفذ من هذه الاجزاء
المطلوبه علما بان اوروبا والولايات
المتحده تستخدم معدات تعمل وفقا لمعايير
مختلفه ما يزيد طبعا صعوبه التقديم بدائل
[موسيقى]